hola soy alonso martínez y soy un
moderador de personajes aquí en los
estudios pixar puedo crear los
personajes virtuales que los animadores
usan para darles vida y si hago bien mi
trabajo no solamente las personas que
leerán que son reales sino que también
se convertirán en amigos cercanos estoy
parado en la galería de arte de pixar
este lugar está dedicado a celebrar todo
el arduo trabajo que se realiza para que
estas películas sean geniales todos los
departamentos en pixar son importantes
en el desarrollo de las historias y en
el departamento de personajes cuando
diseñamos nuestros personajes contamos
una historia a través de las formas de
los personajes uno de mis ejemplos
favoritos es de la película
y es que carla está diseñado como una
caja no atrapado en las emociones de
todos los momentos difíciles que tuvo en
su vida pero rosell tiene la forma de un
huevo
ambos son símbolos de los personajes que
representan para crear grandes
personajes como estos
necesitamos hacer herramientas que
faciliten a los artistas crear estas
formas de las que estamos hablando y que
al mismo tiempo sea más eficiente para
la computadora tratar con todos esos
datos este es el tema para esta lección
quédate aquí para saber más
en la lección sobre modelado ambiental
vimos cómo hacer hojas de pasto usando
parábolas pero las parábolas no son
suficientes para describir la
expresividad de los personajes por
ejemplo aquí tenemos una escultura de la
mano de jerry si el del juego de jerry y
para describir superficies complejas
como ésta es donde entra la subdivisión
como vimos en el vídeo anterior la
subdivisión es extremadamente expresiva
en la primera parte de la lección vimos
detenidamente cómo la subdivisión se
puede utilizar para crear formas
complejas y después en la parte 2
profundizamos más en la matemática de la
subdivisión la mayoría de las
matemáticas que usamos aquí en pixar han
existido por cientos o miles de años
pero la subdivisión es diferente en
realidad fue inventada hace solo 40 años
y aún es un área activa de la
investigación la piel de nuestros
personajes
en un espacio tridimensional pero por
ahora observaremos las curvas en dos
dimensiones empezando con un polígono de
cuatro puntos podemos agregar más puntos
dividiendo eso es agregando puntos
medios a los bordes puedo hacerlo más
suave moviendo cada punto desde donde se
encuentra ahora hasta el punto medio con
respecto al siguiente a esto le llamamos
el paso promedio
repitiendo divisiones y promedios
creamos una serie de curvas cada vez más
suaves ahora imaginen que son un artista
en pixar y se les pide que creen una
figura como esta
usando el siguiente interactivo vean qué
tan cerca pueden llegar